With a bullet to the face and a bunch of traumatic
memories rising to the surface, the first
trailer for Sony's Bloodshot is finally here.
And after what's felt like an eternity of
waiting, the footage surely should have been
met with thunderous applause and about a thousand
posts per minute on social media.
Vin Diesel playing Ray Garrison, a murdered
Marine who comes back to life and is infused
with nanotechnology to become the killing
machine known as Bloodshot?
Academy Award-winning screenwriter Eric Heisserer
joining forces with scribe Jeff Wadlow to
pen the script?
First-time feature film director Dave Wilson
bringing the famous Valiant Comics character
to the big screen for the first time ever?
Sounds like a recipe for comic book movie
success that would start with the release
of the first trailer.
But when Sony dropped the first Bloodshot
trailer on Monday, October 21, many fans were
left disappointed by what they saw.
The biggest gripe some fans have about the
first Bloodshot trailer is that it doesn't
feel like a trailer at all it feels like an
entire film condensed into 2 minutes and 40
seconds.
Many people across Twitter and in the comments
section of the trailer on YouTube expressed
dissatisfaction over the trailer seemingly
spoiling all the narrative beats of the film.
One user tweeted:
"Whoever made this trailer, should be fired.
Spoiled the entire movie in just 2 [minutes]."
Another wondered why the trailer didn't show
off just "a few action sequences" instead
of apparently laying all its cards out on
the table.
They wrote:
"Seriously why do they give away the whole
plot?
Only a few action sequences should be enough
to build some hype."
Over on YouTube, even more people were upset
over the evidently spoiler-heavy trailer.
One user wrote, quote, "When the movie comes
out I'd say I watched [it] already just from
this trailer."
Another reason some fans were let down by
the brand-new Bloodshot trailer?
They feel Bloodshot doesn't look like Bloodshot
he just looks like Vin Diesel.
One less-than-impressed Twitter user wrote:
"Looks very generic, I would have preferred
something that embraced its comic origins
more.
I mean, he doesn't look like Bloodshot at
all, it's just Vin Diesel.
In not embracing the look of the comic they've
made it seem way more bland and generic."
Someone else tweeted, quote, "I don't know
a ton about Bloodshot, but I'm fairly sure
he doesn't just look like regular Vin Diesel."
One fan on Reddit was particularly displeased
with the character design — or, perhaps
more accurately, lack thereof — shown in
the first Bloodshot trailer.
In a thread on the movies subreddit, they
wrote:
"I'm usually not a stickler for this sort
of thing, but the most core aspect of the
character design is that his body is pure
white, he has a giant red dot on his chest,
and his eyes are red, and that was completely
abandoned for peachy Vin [Diesel].
I guess it just feels like they didn't even
really wanna try to make this an adaptation
of the comic.
Maybe I'm bitter, I just wanted more from
this."
Of course, there's a strong chance that the
reason why Bloodshot simply looks like everyday
Vin Diesel in this first trailer is because
his transformation into the character fans
know and love from the Valiant Comics will
happen elsewhere in the film, during a sequence
not shown in the trailer.
Since the footage did reveal quite a bit about
the plot of Bloodshot, perhaps the film's
team is holding off on revealing Bloodshot
in all his glory until later.
Plus, it's worth noting that the trailer does
feature a blink-and-you'll-miss-it shot of
a pale-skinned, red-eyed Diesel so who knows?
Thankfully for Sony executives, the Bloodshot
cast and creative team, and fans at home,
this is just the first taste of the forthcoming
flick.
As Bloodshot nears its February 21, 2020 release
date, there will likely be several more trailers,
teasers, TV spots, and promotional material
rolled out to boost anticipation.
If you weren't blown away by this initial
trailer, perhaps a future one will change
your mind.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.